va se faire vacciner écoutez vous savez
moi au début je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai fouillé plus de pandémie et
plus rien j'y crois de moins en mois
parce que quand je vois seulement 2 %
avouent même pas 1.5 poppers la
population mondiale vacciner je vous dis
que ben ali variant ils vont faire comme
au brésil
ils vont commencer à aussi plus vous en
aurez plus ils vont avoir des plus durs
et qui vont arriver chez nous j'ai peur
de ça est vraiment je n'étais pas dans
ce petit qui encore quelques mois mais
on va y arriver on va plier l'anglais on
va plus en parler et tout le monde va
fasciner
on s'en rend bien compte bien au niveau
de la france au niveau mondial on n'est
pas à la hauteur en termes de 26 mona on
a on a trop tardé à fermer
il est arrivé en france 2 février
d'accord et vous avez là la différence
par rapport à mai à l'aéroport attend
dsk tu es l'italie parvient on n'est pas
obligé d'être tous complètement compte
tout le temps se dire est ce que vous
savez ce qui s'est passé moi j'en avais
dit comme ça c'est sourire c'est le sait
mais tout la pause rien compris
conneries à longueur de journée sans
rien lire sans rien écouté et puis je
dire fermez là mais attends toi dominé
d'ailleurs il a parlé pendant un quart
d'heure bon c'est bon souvenir en italie
sinon il s'est passé un score par m
c'est à dire c'est que au départ qu'est
ce qui fait passer italien cette bande
de cons ils ont fermé
on avait dit en italie les scientifiques
italiens tout le monde avait dit qu'il
fallait pas le faire
ben comme effectivement personne ne lit
rien écrit rien il avait fait quoi et de
l'iso rien qu'est ce qu'ils avaient fait
ils ont fermé les liaisons entre pékin
et rome
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé eh ben ils
sont tous passés par le hub européen et
donc concrètement les mecs qui étaient à
pékin ils sont passés par les pays bas
ils sont passés par l'allemagne
et ils sont arrivés en italie sans qu'on
puisse les contrôler parce qu'on savait
pas guen qui venaient de chine
c'est le problème pour que ça marche les
la fermeture des frontières aériennes il
faut que tous les états membres
ah oui les étals et en même temps ça
il a raison mais est ce parce qu'on perd
le contrôle
mais incapable de tracer les gens enfin
c'est du bon sens quoi c'est du beau
mais là c'est pas mal la visio raconter
des conneries faut réfléchir quarry bay
hill merveilleux maintenant c'est trois
divisions
mais non c'est pas trop tard ce qu'il
fallait mais effectivement c'est pas
compliqué ils sont 20% en au portugal
on attendait foot us et robin d'abord
effectivement il ya plusieurs notions
est-ce que ce variant brésilien c'est
quand même le thème de l'émission il
faut en avoir peur alors d'abord moi
j'ai une question j'ai entendu ludovic
toro expliqué que c'était très dangereux
et qu'on allait tous mourir ça j'ai
compris j'ai résisté
ou alors est alors que jesse survivre à
tout le monde alors compris qu'il est
quand même si on s'en inquiète ce qu'il
est plus dangereux plus contaminant et
concerne effectivement les patients plus
jeunes
ouais bien alors maintenant je te poser
une question quels sont tes sources
et pourquoi ta ta ta ta profession j'ai
tourné la question mais à l'écouter
c'est bizarre parce que cyril hanouna
les mêmes sources quand il a fait
l'introduction non c'est vrai qu'on doit
son pt pourquoi parce qu' est-ce que tu
connais requis que 13 du code de
déontologie médicale
lorsque le médecin participent à une
action d'information du public de
caractère éducatif et sanitaire qu'elle
conçoit le moyen de diffusion
il le doit faire état que de
connaissances que de données confirmées
où est la preuve de prudence
mais voilà là aussi attendait à 206 les
répercussions de ses alter ego du public
donc moi j'ai le ministère attend le
nommé au ministère de la santé le dow et
du brésil accompagné de tous les
réanimateurs qu'on fait cette
publication mois les biens sans
complication mais attends tu vérifions
entre le monde ça met à tomber les
smartphones ne sera pas une mamie
c'est que moi je